[Music]
it is my pleasure to introduce Varity
price
[Music]
[Applause]
DTM Verity price is someone who beli
leaves in chasing your dreams she's gone
from walking
750 mil across Europe in hiking shoes in
memory of her parents to performing
original songs in high heels in front of
stages that are packed in Nashville and
New York from acting in what she admits
might be be levil movies films with
Steven Seagal and Shan Austin to to
speaking on two tedex stages she went
from single at 40 to happily married at
43 and became a mother to a beautiful
baby boy long after doctors said it was
impossible and then in lockdown She
chased another dream and in
2021 made history as the first Speaker
from Africa to be crowned world champion
of public
[Applause]
speaking with a degree in Psychology
from the University of Cape Town and an
accredited debono thinking facilitator
Varity has presented to hundreds of
companies over the last 15 years in
2022 she was invited to be a faculty
member of the University of Cape Town's
Graduate School of Business rated the
top business school in Africa
here she forms part of an Executive
Education Department and delivers her
content as part of transformational work
they do with organizations across the
African continent when it comes to
making your dreams a reality Verity
believes you need to act out of the box
more than think out of it and now all
the way from South Africa to help us
design our future
and
think and think ahead for the crowd
please welcome Verity
price thank you conference
chair I've chased a lot of Dreams in my
life
but I have to tell you not in my wildest
dreams that I ever imagine I would be on
this stage speaking to this audience in
the
Bahamas so am I safe to say there's a
lot of Dreams in the room today yeah so
if you've got Big Dreams big hopes big
aspirations put up your hand put yes in
the chat put up two hands if they're
really big okay thank
you now when you think think about that
dream or that goal put up your other
hand if you ever feel afraid concerned
what if it doesn't work out what if I
fail what if something goes wrong put up
two hands if that fear is really real do
you know what this
means you're
human our dreams excite us and they
terrify
us but in the 15 years that I've been
working with hundreds of companies tens
of thousands of people helping them to
change their thinking so that they can
reach their dreams I've come to see what
really makes the difference is if you
are asking two questions or giving one
answer have I got any parents here today
yes some of you don't sound sure do you
know are you we got parents
here if you didn't say yes were you were
child once okay so you know this when
children learn to speak what is that
irritating question they ask all the
time h
and then when they become teenagers they
change it they add another word what do
they say why not okay they start pushing
back I hear you and your rules and they
push back and so by the time we're
adults until we die we have a one-word
answer what do we
say
no because have you ever said that
before because I said so because those
are the rules because that's how it's
done because it's safer that way
and before you know it because becomes
the box it becomes a reaction to life
where we survive but we don't Thrive are
you here because you want to thrive yeah
okay good has anyone ever told you to
think outside the
box well I want you to consider that all
you need to think outside of is the
because all the reasons it can't be done
and start asking why am I doing it this
way why not do it differently and
consider all the reasons it can be done
now you might be wondering why is verity
so passionate about this I'm going to
tell you 20 years ago I was surviving
the music industry I was an aspiring
singer and songwriter I had Big Dreams I
wanted to T the world I wanted to top
the charts I wanted to be interviewed on
Oprah I didn't care what color her couch
was yes yes yes but two years into my
career the only thing I was touring was
the bar at the end of my
street so on top of that I then
discovered it was going to cost me
$40,000 to record my first album that
was a big pothole between me and my
dream and my reaction to that problem
was to
moan I became one of those people who
arrives at a party with their problem
and then they find some poor person and
they spend the whole night them how hard
and how high and fair their life is have
you ever met someone like
this I hope they are not sitting in your
seat eventually I realized I either
needed to give up or I needed to get
creative which is the better
choice get creative absolutely so I got
on the phone to my older much wiser
sister Kay now Kay is the bookor in our
family I asked her we could have coffee
and she arrived and told me that she'
just finished reading a book called the
six thinking hats by Edward debono she
was excited to see if she could use his
framework for problem solving to solve
my problem now I don't have time to take
you through his work today but I want to
take you through the thinking we did
that day the first thing we realized was
that I was so focused on my problem I
hadn't looked up to focus on a solution
and if you have got obstacles between
you and where you want to be it comes
down to are you asking extraordinary
questions because extraordinary
questions get extraordinary
Solutions and so my extraordinary
question that day was how can I market
and release an album in South Africa
without going into debt I put my problem
into the question I wanted to give my
brain a challenge to
solve next we stepped back and looked at
the facts of my current reality what did
I know what did I need to know now I
knew that I didn't have
$40,000 my bank balance agreed on that
but I also knew that I had 200 songs
written I had a band I had a website I
had a network of supportive people
didn't know how you got music into the
stores how you got music on the radio
but that mere Act of looking at the
facts showed me things I could be doing
to move closer to my dream
next K said to me Verity how are you
feeling about this but before I started
she said uhuh name the feeling don't
explain the feeling like okay well I'm
overwhelmed frustrated anxious irritated
scared tired it was a very long list I'd
had a long time to build up some
feelings but the amazing thing is is
when you name a feeling but don't
explain it it just gets it out of your
head puts it on the paper paper and
clears up your mind to keep
thinking next she said Verity what is
working in your career now this was
embarrassing in 2 years I hadn't once
looked at if anything was working but
when I looked I found it I have songs
written I have a band I have a website
there's less competition in South Africa
and when I focused on the positives I
started feeling more
positive then she said okay let's think
how you have been thinking for the last
two years what's not working this was
easy I don't have the money and because
I don't have the money if I borrow it
I'm going to go into debt does this kind
of thinking sound familiar to you yeah
okay isn't it interesting how easy it is
to look at all the reasons you can't do
something but here's the beauty if you
look at the positives before you look at
the problems it's much easier to then
consider
possibilities and so I suddenly looked
at everything we'd written down and I
went
hm just because I don't have $40,000 it
was a problem and a fact why not
leverage of the fact that my songs are
written I have a band I have a website
and imagine now you know you are
accessing creative thinking when you say
things like imagine or wouldn't it be
amazing if and I went imagine if I asked
everyone I know to go onto my website
and buy copies of my album before I Rec
record it imagine if I sell something
that doesn't exist and the people who
buy it replace a record label now Kay
was an amazing thinking partner she said
that's awesome what else could you do
because here's the thing with thinking
it is far easier for you to tame a wild
idea than it is for you to make a boring
idea
interesting okay so I said all right
this is pretty different don't know if
it's ever been done before and I said
well well maybe I can make a difference
and I decided that I would give 10% of
everything I raised to split it between
women shelters in South Africa and
empowering other
artists two years I had been stuck 30
minutes of thinking differently and I
had a way forward I was going to sell an
album that didn't exist people were
going to replace a record label and we
were going to give 10% to empowering
artist and uplifting woman now you might
be looking at this and going well Verity
isn't that just called
crowdfunding and you'd be right but do
you know what this idea was called in
crazy I left that coffee knowing I would
be crazy not to try and I also left with
a choice was I going to act on my idea
or leave it written on a
napkin because ideas have no value
action has
value and and if you are prepared to
flirt with failure that's the only time
you're ever going to get to dance with
success and so the first action I took
was I started telling people about my
idea two things happened everyone in the
music industry said that won't work
because that's not how music is funded
everyone who wasn't in the music
industry said why not that's crazy let's
do it first person who said yes was a
guy his name was Guy funnily enough we
met at a dinner party he heard I was a s
he said do you have an album I said no
but I have an idea and while I was
speaking he reached into his pocket
pulled out his wallet and said I'll take
the first copy wow and I kind of looked
at him and I looked at the money and
then I asked the obvious question guy
why are you supporting me you haven't
heard me sing he said Verity isn't that
the point of your project said yes give
me that
money but in that moment Guy taught me a
life changing lesson and that is that
your word creates your world the way you
speak about your goal your dream where
you going that's what determines who
shows up to help you get there and the
more I told people I was selling an
album that didn't exist the more I sold
it it's a very long story short over
2,000 people in 25 countries bought that
album I released it in 2008 they sent me
pictures poems postcards I even got a
proposal from a guy in Edinburgh but I
think he wanted to make more than an
album so I said
no as a result of them saying yes to my
idea and to my dream we were able to
give over $4,000 to charity I could buy
supplies for the shelters I could pay
for two singers to record their demos
and one of them Mimi and tangu are
pictured there in the middle went on in
2010 to be named best young jazz artist
in South Africa isn't that amazing
[Applause]
so I'm just going to address the
elephant in the room you do know that
I'm not a famous pop star you you I'm
still open to that interview with Oprah
just
saying but what happened with this
project was that I got better known for
thinking than I did for singing I was
suddenly being asked to speak all over
the world and I'd say wow can I bring my
band and they'd say
no come teach us how to think aead of
the crowd because ultimately that's what
people were interested in there were
documentaries and news articles
worldwide it was one of the first online
crowdfunding projects HSBC Bank in the
UK put it at number 25 of their top 100
business ideas and Cape Town singer
Verity even appeared in cart blanch the
James Bond novel by Jeffrey D.A I don't
know if you know what that means I'm
officially South Africa's first Bond
girl
[Applause]
but the most unexpected thing that
happened was when I got sent a picture
of Edward debono the author of six
thinking hats holding a copy of my
album holding proof that I'd acted on
the idea Kay and I met him on his last
ever visit to South Africa and he
invited as to teach his work and it
changed my life now imagine if I'd never
never acted on that
idea none of this would have
happened now it's not the path my soul
or my egoo wanted for me I wanted to be
a pop star but what I've learned is that
sometimes when you get onto the road
that your soul has planned for you life
gets so much
easier so I want to Circle back to your
road to that dream that you put your
hand up about
earlier and I think you'll agree with me
that when it comes to chasing your dream
dreams if you don't design your future
someone or something else is going to
design it for you and do you want to
design your future here at home I hope
at home is also saying yes do you want
to design your future yes okay let's
look at how you do that here's the
framework hold that dream in your heart
and now I want you to look to the
Horizon of that dream and get very clear
on what is your desired outcome you need
to frame this as an extraordinary
question how how can I and then put some
stretch in it this question needs to
make your brain a little bit
uncomfortable so that it can get
creative when you've got that Focus step
back and look at the fact of your
current
reality and then take some time to check
in with how you're feeling but please
remember name the feelings don't explain
the feelings you getting this and then I
want to ask you to spend a lot of time
don't wait two years to look for the
positives of what's happening with
regards to your dream look for the
positives what's working what's going
for you how can you leverage that to
take you forward and then get very
honest about what's in the way what are
the weaknesses the pitfalls the potholes
the
problems and then I want you to fill
those potholes in with your ideas it
helps to invite the K in your life to
help you with this I find having a
thinking partner makes a big difference
but this is where you need to have wild
ideas that you can tame rather than
boring ideas than you're trying to make
interesting because when you have that
idea and it excites you it Delights you
it ignites a passion in you that's when
you have to act that's when you have to
dare to flirt with failure that's when
you have to let your word create your
world and I'm not going to tell you it's
easy because it's not dreams are things
we do when we're awake not when we're
asleep but when you step out your
comfort zone and you see where it can
take you it can be a lifechanging
journey so is that a journey that you
want to go on to make your dream a
reality yes yes yes yes I see Lisa
Nichols is going to be with us all
weekend yes
yes so I want you to really take this
forward with you is that your thinking
that you do today is affecting the
results you get tomorrow and every day
you have the choice to look at the
problems you facing and think about them
differently so my Toast Master is here
my toast Masters at home what I want to
ask you and I just want to get the Buy
in from you that you are going to do
this let's see I'm switching mics we're
going to get interesting here are you
ready to design your
future are you ready to think ahead of
the
crowd are you ready to get onto the road
that your soul has planned for
you well to help you on that Journey I'd
like to leave you with a soundtrack
something that you can sing while you
start walking and I've lost them they're
going to play it for me very nicely I've
got amazing my band is at the back of
the room they're going to give us they
are going to give us a song would you
like a song can I finish with the song
This is my invitation to chase your
dreams because you'd be crazy not to
try maybe I'm crazy thinking that this
might work maybe I'm crazy wanting
something that might hurt maybe it's
Madness to start something that might
end maybe it's
easier to just not begin I may be
delusional believe in this stands a
chance when so many before have proved
that good things don't last seems a
little bit naive to step in
anyway but I'd be crazy if I didn't tell
make a step around the corner
confronting all that I don't know the
storms I weather those times of being
out of control not having all the
answers there's never reason not to try
what if the right Brothers hadn't
believed that they could
[Music]
fly I believe that we
you be crazy NS try I hope you get out
there I hope you chase your dreams you
give yourself permission to think ahead
of the crowd and when you get there
please send me a poem a postcard and a
picture thank you Toast
[Applause]
[Music]
Masters